en direct dans ce journal gérard
vespière fondateur du site le monde
décrypté et chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonjour gérard vespière merci de
répondre à nos questions vous selon rich
est hyper doan
la turquie est assez forte militairement
pour déchirer les cartes et les
documents immoraux d'après kyriakos
minnesota qui ça les provocations
s'arrête le dialogue commence jusqu'où
vont aller les deux hommes au je crois
qu'on n'ira pas beaucoup plus loin il ya
fondamentalement deux problèmes il y a
un problème effectivement de découpage
géographique euros à proximité des côtes
turques
imaginons des îles anglaises à quelques
kilomètres des côtes françaises et que
l'on trouve du gaz et du pétrole
il faudrait effectivement pouvoir par
les bons à entre la france et
l'angleterre l'a cette fois ci à erdogan
réagi à la façon dont on lui on lui
connaît et deuxièmement l'autre problème
auquel fait face la turquie ça problèmes
intérieurs un problème intérieur
économique à profond alliés a donc là la
crise à ducobu 19 la quitte la crise
sanitaire
l'économie va mal la monnaie est
d'évaluer à la l'industrie touristique
ne peut pas prendre le relais puisque
effectivement il ya beaucoup moins de
touristes cette année
ah voilà la situation intérieure il a
perdu les dernières élections
municipales est difficile donc on
réunissant avec un sentiment
profondément nationaliste à la turquie
et les turcs autour de lui pour
l'extérieur au lieu de regarder
l'assiette que l'on a devant soi pour un
repas bien en le père de gan invite son
peuple à regarder les flots de la
méditerranée il ya une gesticulation
donc militaire mais aussi avec une avec
une résonance politique intérieure la
grèce et la turquie font tous deux
partie de l'otan on sait l organisation
atlantique annonce
cette semaine que les dirigeants grecs
et turcs avaient accepté d'engager des
pourparlers techniques ça a été démenti
il ya des négociations ou pas et si oui
où en sont les pourparlers il ya des
contacts certainement au moins avec des
intermédiaires et la prochaine étape
sera des rondes la roja pardon à des
contacts directs entre grecs et turcs
on ne peut aller que dans cette
direction là parce qu'à partir du moment
où voyez vous il y a des richesses il
faut les exploiter et un plus les
tensions durent a plus la date
d'exploitation et biens reculent donc
tout le monde a envie de pouvoir se
partager ou profiter à deux milliards ou
de dizaines de milliards de dollars qui
sont à saouler les flots de la
méditerranée est bien le plus tôt sera
forcément le mieux
vous parlez de richesse justement
concernant les gisements qui se
trouverait en méditerranée orientale
quelle quantité d'hydrocarbures se
trouveraient sous les eaux vous parler
de beaucoup de milliards d'après ce que
j'ai compris
absolument il y a eu le voit sur toute
la partie sud oriental de la
méditerranée depuis la libye depuis
l'egypte israël chypre
vous avez toute cette corne orientale de
la méditerranée où il ya des gisements
très important à l'egypte vise
l'autonomie gazière dans les prochaines
années
donc il y a des ressources importantes
actuellement il ya des recherches donc
du côté turc avec des navires
océanographiques mais aa pas douter il y
à des milliards de dollars enfouie sous
le plancher océanique de la militaire à
l'est mais on sait que la france est
monté au créneau à la fin août face à la
turquie aux côtés notamment de la grèce
de l'italie de chypre mais on a peu
entendu parilla ces dernières heures sur
le sujet pourquoi est selon vous quelles
réactions prochaine de
la france la france a déjà pris des
positions en envoyant quelques bateaux
supplémentaires en envoyant quelques
rafales
maintenant il s'agit on a des limites et
donc notre position et notre ligne à je
pense qu'il n'y aura pas de mouvement
nouveau sauf vraiment des dispositions
turc que l'on n'envisage pas
actuellement mais je ne crois pas que
les turcs eux or aux hommes verront
prendrons des décisions pour une
escalade militaire
il en est pas question cela retardera la
solution à de ceux de cette tension n'y
a pas de conflit une tension
donc l'objectif est de d'avoir le
maximum de cartes dans le jeu turc et
c'est ce que les turcs essaye de faire
actuellement
donc en rose on ira parle vers d'autres
affrontements merci j'ai un vestiaire
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur associé
à la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient et fondateur du site le
monde décrypté
merci